[Music]
hello everyone how you doing it's Pete
also notice now though here to give you
another one of our first looks of one of
the games called Cuba factorial this
game is a settler building game which
allows you to have different it's
different people I should say people to
be brought into your settlement and from
there you get to build your town now
from this portion of the game that we
saw the beginning allows you to pick the
different types of starting people you
can either have for instance six people
just regular settlers to move around
with or settlers and animals or just one
settler and some animals so it all
depends upon how difficult you want to
make it now from the gameplay that I saw
it was pretty much a standard type of
colony management building type game now
it was it was a little difficult to play
in the beginning there was no real
tutorial so I kind of had to use my
intuition for the other previous games
that I ended up playing to allow myself
to get the knowledge of what I was doing
now going through the process I kind of
just started with the normal thinking of
when I played rim world and I was just
like okay we got a farm some materials
get some stockpiles put some farms down
and then start building housing or
something to do from there and when I
did that I was like okay cool
so I put some farms down and put some
pastures down for some animals and it
worked out pretty nicely but for
instance my house wasn't being built now
I kind of had to click around and figure
out what was going on at that
now I chucked down a lot of trees I
chopped down a chop to urge to mind a
bunch of rocks and they were just
sitting there and I didn't understand
why they weren't being moved into my
stock piles so then I had to go into my
stock piles and pick every specific item
that I wanted to be placed into that
stock pile so I ended up placing the
wood the rocks all of those things into
those stockpiles to then allow them to
be transported into what I thought would
be the building of a house and when I
clicked on the house it would say cannot
be built missing supplies and then I
started realizing okay so if I click on
the buildings it'll actually tell me
what I need to do so I then clicked on
the house and says you need to build
supplies so then I was like okay what
supplies do I need and making it gave
you the list of things and then from
there you'd end up going into trying to
figure out how to build those so then I
was like okay well there should be some
type of like workshop or mill or
blacksmith or something along those
lines so I ended up taking those
blacksmithing people and I ended up
putting them into the location and then
I said then they started building that
and I said okay cool and then I tried to
assign a person to it and I had no idea
how to do that and then I was like okay
so I got a I guess I got a click this
colony button up here on the upper right
and then choose the person and and then
eventually though there but he didn't go
there I said what's going on so then I
ended up choosing the item so I was like
oh okay the items are green green
usually means go they're gonna be made
and it wasn't being made and I was like
okay what is going on and then I
realized the reason why this game is
Cuba factorial is because of the game
factory that ended up making everything
automated so I was like all right so in
that game you'd end up having to click
different types of objects to allow them
to pull into different locations so I
ended up clicking on the workshop and
then I click on the stockpile and you
see an arrow for
and then you're like oh okay that means
I guess you're going to be taking
supplies from this location and put it
into the stock bottle let's see what
happens when I did in the reverse so
then I looked at the stockpile and then
I clicked the workshop and then it said
okay we're gonna take supplies and start
going back and forth and then they
started moving back and forth and making
those supplies and I was like awesome
this is great and then trying to end up
making the housing so the housing ended
up working they did end up starting to
build that and I was like oh okay pretty
good pretty easy okay now that I kind of
understand the the global thought
process of everything this is cool so I
tried to then do something else and I
tried to make a wheat farm and I was
like cannot make weak soil bad I was
like okay so what else should I end up
doing them with this so I ended up
looking around on the map and then on
the upper portion of the map I saw a
farm with wheat on it and then I
realized you need a different soil so
there are desert soil regular plain soil
and I guess a moist soil and then you'd
end up having those and then you could
plant there and farm on there
so eventually I ended up being able to
chop down this mid portion mountain that
was in the middle of the place and then
being able to go up north and then end
up taking those farms over and being
able to start producing wheat for other
things
now the beginning was a little little
weird because I didn't I didn't
understand how to play like I was saying
but Oh once I kind of got into the
groove I kinda I was like okay this
isn't that bad this is kind of easy it
was also only the first level and I was
like alright this this is gonna be fun
now from other types of gameplay that
I've seen I've seen that there's also
fighting so you have to end up fighting
like spiders and things that are turning
endangered your your home now
this game is in early access so they
consider this an indie game
early access and it was a Kickstarter
game so there are portions of it that I
feel like can they can have some growth
on but all the gameplay portion of it I
thought was good I thought that they
have the basic plan basic ideas and
basic things that they're gonna need to
be able to produce this game and push
forward I think that is fantastic this
key was given to us by publisher and
developer Mirko Sethi and we ended up
kind of taking this key and we wanted to
wanted to see what what what could be
done and I liked it as for the graphics
of it pixel art it's an indie game most
indie games are pixel art now I like the
pixel art look and feel I thought I
thought this was a little over pixely
like they just decided to go hey we're
going into paint we're picking the boxes
and we're gonna make the most boxy
things possible and make them
three-dimensional
how else can I put it and I thought they
could have done a lot better on that but
being that it is a pixel art it was okay
now as for the replay value of it it's
fun I would like to end up getting a
little farther in the campaign to see
how much you can do to see what else you
can do so I'm gonna continue to play
this off stream and and see how far we
can get and most more than likely we're
gonna end up try to put something else
later on once we've completed it this
this game is out right now on early
access on Steam the price of it's not
that bad it's pretty good so if you want
to end up gonna take it you know play
with it and see how it goes I would
definitely recommend it and I would
definitely show these the this developer
some love because you know they're
they're doing some good work and you can
see that the automation portion which is
what I find to be the most interesting I
ended up putting a brewery down anymore
well take water and we're gonna put it
in the stock bottle with water
well top out perfect okay and then it
said we need flowers so I ended up
taking one of our Lots clicking it
changing it over to flowers and they
ended up just starting to take the
flowers and move it over it was great
I thought that the automation portion of
this worked out very very well and was
working pretty flawlessly and I think
that they have a very very solid base
for what could be a very very large game
just like rimworld when it originally
was published it was a very very small
scale it had very few little details in
it that allowed you to create the world
and environment that
on it and with Cuba fact Orion
definitely have that it definitely can
be seen as something that you have to
worry about some internal conflicts
between your civilians
you definitely have some more external
people attacking like donkeys or you can
have wild beasts of some sort
or something like that you can
definitely have more than just one thing
that can end up being in there and its
really good so I would love to see the
farther portions of it because you can
end up automating it using trains
Zeppelin's you have land tracks down
number for those trains
so I love endgame of things and this I
think is gonna have some great endgame
and I cannot wait to get into it so
everybody this is Pete also known as now
that once again I just wanted to tell
you thank you very much for checking out
our first look video now the iron lives
podcast is on Sundays keep an eye on our
Twitter to see when we will be going
live and getting those that link so you
can check us out I like to thank thank
you once again
Mira CO Sethi for the key for us to use
and have a fantastic day
thanks everybody
you